On December 13th,
U.S. prosecutors charged FTX founder
Sam Bankman-Fried with eight counts of fraud and conspiracy.
I think it's fair to say that by anyone's life,
this is one of the biggest financial frauds in American history.
The charges were announced amid a series of events playing out across two countries
that also included an arrest in the Bahamas,
a criminal indictment, and a congressional hearing on the crypto exchange's sudden demise.
Bahamian police said they took Bankman-Fried into custody
at his apartment in Nassau on December 12th for charges of various financial
offenses against laws of the United States,
which are also offenses against laws of the Commonwealth of the Bahamas.
Authorities said the arrest was made based on an indictment filed by the
U.S. Attorney's Office for the Southern District of New York.
Bankman-Fried and his co-conspirators stole billions of dollars from FTX customers.
The indictment accuses Bankman-Fried of misappropriating FTX.com
customers' deposits and using those to pay expenses and debts of
Alameda Research, his crypto hedge fund.
Since FTX filed for bankruptcy in November.
Bankman-Fried has said in multiple interviews that he bore responsibility for the company's collapse,
but he did not knowingly commit any fraud.
I was trying to do the best I could. Obviously, that wasn't nearly as good as I thought it was.
Bankman-Fried is reviewing the charges with his legal team and considering all of his legal options, his lawyer said.
Also on December 13th, the Securities and Exchange Commission alleged
in a civil lawsuit that Bankman-Fried diverted customer funds from the start of FTX to support Alameda.
The SEC says that while he spent lavishly on office space and condominiums in the
Bahamas and sank billions of dollars of customer funds into speculative venture
investments,
Bankman-Fried's house of cards began to crumble.
His brazen multiyear scheme finally came to an end when FTX,
Alameda and their tangled web of affiliates filed for bankruptcy on November 11, 2022.
That collapse has had far-reaching consequences for FTX customers,
for its investors, and for its counter parties.
The Commodity Futures Trading Commission,
another U.S. markets regulator, filed a separate lawsuit on the same day linking his alleged fraudulent
conduct at Alameda and FTX to markets that the CFTC regulates.
The complaints are the latest twist in a
saga that has rattled the world of cryptocurrencies and has caught the attention of U.S. lawmakers.
Rest assured that this committee will not stop
until we uncover the full truth behind the collapse of FTX.
At a congressional hearing in Washington,
FTX's new chief executive told lawmakers that the company has incurred losses in excess of
$7 billion.
This isn't this isn't Uh you know,
sophisticated whatsoever. This is just plain old embezzlement.
Hours after the criminal indictment was unsealed,
a magistrate judge in the Bahamas denied bail
to Bankman-Fried and said he should be remanded to Bahamian custody until February 8, 2023.